now we have this Fox News Alert on This
Global day of jihad there were massive
Pro Palestinian protests in major cities
all around the world from Baghdad to
Rome and New York and Los Angeles our
very own Sarah Carter was with
demonstrators in Time Square in New York
City and here's what they told her
listen to
this how do you respond when people say
look these babies were beheaded some of
them were burned to death there were
children that were killed
why why not speak out against that and
then you know protest later why protest
now because they're already killing
hundreds of lives right now even as we
speak and we're protesting until
something ends something stops for us
you know do you think it's going to ever
stop when you well the problem is as
long that Gaza as long as Gaza is led by
a terror organization I don't see any
difference do you care about the babies
that were beheaded
they would never Beed that was a madeup
story not true it's show me the pictures
now so what about show me the picture
you're a lion full of you're full of
they did not kill their babies that is
so no bab there's no validation of that
whatsoever there is no proof of that
Netanyahu is basically running his own
Narrative of what he wants to excuse
himself JY killing and Jud sighing and
holoc costing all the Palestinians it's
a shame that Hamas can't stand here in
the middle of New York City and say
every every day this is crazy this is
crazy I don't I don't understand how the
American people don't afraid from this
guy I don't understand one man's
terrorist is another man's Freedom
Fighter don't forget
it massive crowds all in denial all
believing lies um it should shock your
conscience now remember this all comes
at a time when virulent
anti-Semitism uh has seen a very very
ugly Resurgence not just here in the
United States but around the globe
around the world Sarah Carter she was in
the middle of all of that joins us now
with more Sarah I'll be honest uh in
spite of all of the evidence to the
contrary the massive size of the crowd
that you have been in all day it is
shocking to see people that
ignorant that that much in denial that
actually you know I really are
supporting the terrorist attacks against
Israel and and they support it with a
passion that's ABS
Goode yeah that's absolutely true Sean
um we've been out here all day there
have been thousands of pro Palestinian
supporters on the streets here in New
York City in fact they marched all the
way to the consulate and there are still
hundreds on the streets right now as you
can see behind me uh the tensions have
been extraordinarily high today uh
thankfully there hasn't been any
violence but that's not to say Sean that
law enforcement here the NYPD hasn't
been ex very concerned about that
happening they've been doing Yen's work
uh and they have been targeted with uh
all kinds of foul language as you can
imagine um every time they try to move
people out of the way one of the bigger
issues Sean that for me personally that
has happened right
here for one of the bigger issues for me
is I've covered the War I spent eight
years in Afghanistan covering the war
you know that back and forth in the
region I was in Iraq I saw the
atrocities of War I saw what hate did to
those countries and those communities
and we're starting to see it here in the
United States I talked to both
Palestinian supporters people that are
fighting for a Palestinian state out
here and I also spoke to pro-israeli
supporters that were here a smaller
group a far smaller group they were
terrified they said they couldn't
believe the rise in anti-Semitism
whereas on the other side we had the
Palestinian people saying that the
reports coming out of Israel were lies
uh They said that the reports about the
death of the beheadings of the babies
were not true um there is certainly a
lot of conflict this is not not going to
resolve and one of the bigger questions
I had for everyone Sean here today and
you can see there's so many people here
still on the streets is how does this
how does
[Music]
this how does this all our cops are not
getting paid enough by y'all sending
billions Sarah if you want to interview
her you can hear her what does she want
to say tell say upset what would you
like what would what would you like to
say what what and right now I think the
bigger question a lot of people have and
this is the one that I've asked everyone
okay there were 1,200 plus people killed
last weekend on Saturday people killed
that were innocent civilians they were
killed by terrorists
according according to their actions
there were children involved in there
can I say can I speak Hamas do you
consider Hamas a terrorist organization
when that happened we as Muslim were set
we don't condemn that we don't support
that but you guys killing and having a
genocide in Palestine right now is not
okay why is it okay when it's Israel but
when it's Palestinian you guys are like
it's okay cuz Hamas is hiding there
that's not right we as humans need to do
better those are children what would the
reaction be what would the reaction be
and this is my question as well Sean
I've covered the war for a long time and
I've seen this I I my heart breaks
really it does to see so Much Death to
see so Much Death but what would the
reaction be what would the reaction be
if it was the other way around this
weekend so Palestine is the size of
Washington DC you don't need to send
warships to destroy that strip but so
many people don't believe and I asked so
many how many people here believe that
babies were killed and that they were
beheaded by
hamas's nobody believes it nobody
believes it we don't s hey Sarah let me
ask you this Sarah I don't know if you
can hear me we don't support would we do
not support that we as Muslim are
peaceful people we actually matter of
fact no religion supports the killing of
children let me ask you let me ask you
ask about the 260 overwhelming evidence
is against Israel when you open Twitter
you're going to are worried are you
worried though that this war is going to
spill here on the streets of the you ref
to this is this is not a war anymore
this is an extermination camp this is
all what's happening these are
defenseless people against one of the
best militaries in the world and you're
calling this a war this is not a war how
does this end what was the Holocaust
what was the Holocaust wasn't it Hitler
killing the Jews Exterminating the Jews
what are the Jews doing now what are the
Israelis design is who started the war
exting the people of do you believe
there is a two-state solution to this
what do you believe all unite together
and stand up for what's right today the
Empire State Building should have been
red white I mean red white and black not
blue and white they're still supporting
Israel is that was last week like you
said right but today but thousands of
Palestinian children's family died if
there's terrorists where are the names
of those terrorists Israel is so
Advanced that they should have a list of
the name of terrorists they can't pull
one terrorist out just like they got the
Baden dude and they were like here this
is him they can't they can't bring the
names of the I se children and families
are dying Sarah can and wake up and stay
W they are trying div
Sarah
I passion here and the rage and the
anger and Sean I think what the problem
is and we've seen this throughout is
that everybody here has one belief
whereas people on the other side have
another belief and no shaking those
beliefs whether the people here believe
what happened in Israel or whether they
don't on the other side when I spoke to
Israeli supporters you know people that
were were adamantly opposed to what was
happening even here on the streets of
New York City they were saying
anti-Semitism is on the rise they were
saying nobody believes us they were
frightened at what they were seeing on
the streets and you can also see on the
side of the prop Palestinian
that they also feel this intensity and
this rage and that's why I ask is there
a TW State solution yeah give them their
water give them their electricity stop
bombing their hospitals let them if you
don't want them there let them go to
Egypt why are you guys putting a Siege
on everything why are you guys not
letting these people live it's
simple the
Egyptian but right now reports are that
the egptian government is not allowing
people to go into Egypt that they're
being kept on the outside of inside
Israel right now Sean Sean we are
looking at the beginning of what could
be continuing protests throughout the
week and not just here in the United
States but throughout the world it's not
going to end today uh Sean back to you
uh Sarah thank you stay safe hey sea
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interview and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else